[Música]
[Aplausos]
seguramente te han preguntado alguna vez
qué quiere ser de mayor a que sí
si oigo para que si a lo mejor tenía 28
años o 10 o 20 años
y con 30 y con 40 y 70 años te han
preguntado o te has preguntado qué
quieres ser de mayor
yo pregunto a personas mayores que
quieren ser de mayor
y las respuestas son geniales y diversas
una señora mayor hace poco nos dijo que
quería ser guarda forestal ya otro
profesor de ruso pero la mayor parte de
la gente dice yo ya sé mayor yuxi
qué difícil no sé quiero ser feliz
la pregunta es difícil lo sé
porque vamos a analizarlo un poco ya que
quieres
se nos olvidó preguntarle las personas
mayores que quieren es discriminación es
es elevadísimo discriminación por razón
de edad
el paternalismo condescendencia
infantilización
el arancel mo no no no no haga eso no
haga nada que está tomando el sintrom
y si va a caer
esto conduce a la invisibilización a la
marginación muchas personas mayores se
olvidan de preguntarse a sí mismos que
quiero
y poder decidir acerca de lo que quiero
es lo que llamamos autonomía personal
es en españa un derecho por cierto lo
sabían es un derecho subjetivo de
ciudadanía tenemos derecho a poder
decidir sobre todo aquello que nos
afecta a nuestra vida y el estado por
cierto tiene que garantizar que se
ejerce ese derecho incluso en situación
de dependencia no es poca cosa
bueno pues hay personas mayores un poco
desobedientes
y quieren seguir preguntándose qué
quiero quienes ser autónomas
hay por cierto personas profesionales
organizaciones empresas administraciones
que tienen la sensibilidad como para
preguntar las personas mayores qué es lo
que quieren y fundamentan sus servicios
sus intervenciones como centradas en la
persona
sobre la base de lo que quieren lo que
desean su historia de vida
bueno esta es la clave la pregunta que
algunos me dicen no no querrás decir que
quiero hacer lo que quiero tener o donde
quiero vivir que no que quiere ser
muchas personas mayores perder la
identidad con la jubilación
la sociedad nos ha etiquetado con una
profesión yo soy arquitecto y de repente
un día me jubilo
es que me jubilo
me jubilo y ya no sé quién soy bueno hay
otro tipo de pérdidas de identidad
cuando enviudó cuando los chicos se van
de casa cuando no acepto ciertos cambios
de mi cuerpo cuando dejó de hacer lana
de cena de nochevieja
los medios de comunicación continuamente
a las personas mayores las están las
están presentando como un problema como
un gasto robándonos en la identidad
y sabes que hay personas mayores un poco
desobedientes que quiere seguir siendo
que quieren autorrealizarse que quieren
que saben seres multidimensionales
polifacéticos que quieren seguir
teniendo una identidad
mayor bueno
hemos llamado de tantas formas a las
personas mayores a los viejos ancianos
la tercera edad como no nos gustan vamos
cambiando
en personas de edad maduras nos ponemos
finos y ya senior
saben que hay gente que la llama gerón
dolescentes
a mí me gusta persona mayor porque es un
concepto relativo porque cuando mi hijo
mayor me pregunta qué es una películas
de mayores el mayor soy yo
porque mi actividad que tiene 100 años
es la mayor de la familia pero en
nuestra amiga blasa ha cumplido 104 es
mayor que mi tía natividad
es un concepto relativo y eso es
estupendo porque todos somos mayores que
pero vamos a ser mayores que otros
siempre hay futuro siempre proyectos que
planear aunque podemos sentir que nos
queda poco tiempo muchas personas
mayores sienten que les queda poco
tiempo y precisamente con más ahínco
emprenden proyectos como aquel aquel
señor que nos decía con mucha guasa no
dice yo que yo que tengo prisa que yo ya
no compro plátanos verdes
siempre hay futuro
hay personas mayores un poco
desobedientes que quieren seguir
haciendo proyectos que quieren seguir
emprendiendo incluso proyectos que saben
que les van a sobrevivir a ellos y les
van a dejar un legado a las siguientes
generaciones
bueno su pregunta qué quiere ser de
mayor pero no he preguntado
quieres ser mayor
espéralo voluntad de otra manera
quieres envejecer
ella es un poco más de miedo verdad la
palabra
hay muchas teorías sobre el
envejecimiento hay uno que me gusta
mucho no es precisamente de las más
optimistas pero dice que el
envejecimiento es un progreso un proceso
progresivo y continuo de adaptación al
medio
bueno pues ataquemos al medio esto es lo
mío como arquitecto
estos los nuestros somos un equipo y nos
dedicamos a facilitar entornos para
envejecer bien de forma autónoma
saludable activa
pero antes de que nos cuente a qué nos
dedicamos quería contar una clave muy
importante para entender qué es un
entorno para envejecer bien a ver vamos
a imaginarnos mariah 78 años vive en su
adosado sola
tiene artrosis
y ha decidido hoy
salir con sus amigas a tomar un café así
que baja con mucho cuidadito sus tres
tramos de escaleras llega a la calle y
un sol abrasador
placer así muy ancha para caminar para
estupendo pero ni un árbol ni un banco
ni se va a cruzar con una persona sola
en ese barrio a las afueras de la parada
de autobús más lejos de 500 metros
esos son retos que plantea la ciudad hoy
en día hay muchos otros retos como el
autobús que está en movimiento como
cruzó el paso de peatones sin hacer los
100 metros lisos
como tiró la basura en un contenedor que
la palanca es que me cuesta abrirla
no se plantean muchos retos pero dentro
de casa también plantean retos antes
hemos hablado la escalera pero la ir al
baño a las 4 la mañana puede ser toda
una proeza o ponerme unos calcetines
cuando tengo problemas de movilidad o
abrir un paquete de galletas
alguien sabe cómo abrir los paquetes de
galletas estás con él abre fácil este
es que no puedo pero con los las fáciles
yo no puedo
bueno pues mira vamos a solucionarlo me
quedo en casa que venga mi hija a
hacerme la comida a tirarme la basura
fijaos que digo mi hija sabéis que nueve
de cada diez personas que cuidan son
mujeres
esto es para tomar nota y ya lo
hablaremos en otro momento
bueno que venga que me ponga un pañal o
mira lo mejor que me vaya me mande una
residencia vale y allí que me lo hagan
todo
bueno pues aquí está la clave para el
entorno para envejecer bien powell
lawton un psicólogo de gerontólogo
americano hace años formuló lo que
llaman el modelo ecológico de la
competencia que dice una regla muy
sencilla en un entorno donde hay
excesivo reto eso produce frustración y
con ello dependencia pero un entorno
donde hay excesivo apoyo produce atrofia
y con ello dependencia así que
necesitamos un entorno que haya donde
haya un equilibrio entre reto y apoyo
siempre en función de mis competencias
que son cambiantes con el tiempo
cerca de casa había un señor que
salí a todas las mañanas a dar un paseo
tenía alzheimer y hasta casi hasta el
final siguió haciéndose ese reto diario
salí a dar un paseo por el barrio
y se andaba despistado desorientado por
allí siempre porque allí se conocía en
todo siempre había alguien que decía
venga anda para casa
será su apoyo
y es que en estos tiempos de
individualismo
se nos ha olvidado esa forma de apoyo
importantísima que es la comunidad que
precisamente parece una paradoja pero es
la comunidad la que permite que tengamos
mayor autonomía personal porque puedo
desarrollar aquello que yo deseo para mi
vida con la ayuda de los demás
bueno pues hay personas mayores un poco
desobedientes que han decidido contar
con la comunidad que ponen su
inteligencia a disposición de los demás
y crean desde eso que llamamos
inteligencia colectiva creen como dice
nuestro amigo el psicólogo fernando
cembranos que el grupo es más
inteligente que yo
este es uno de los proyectos en donde
estamos absolutamente volcados con
housing
muchas personas nos vienen con esta
conversación de bar siempre es la misma
es curioso
uy
si cuando nos jubilemos nos vamos a
vivir juntos
nos compramos un terrenito construimos
unos pequeños apartamentos unas buenas
zonas comunes donde compartimos
colaboramos
bueno desde hace muchos años ya son
miles de personas las que viven en estas
comunidades empezó en dinamarca en
holanda en los años 70 luego continuó en
eeuu y otros países que construyeron
comunidades que llamaron con housing
collaborative housing las viviendas
colaborativas
empezaron compartiendo cuidados para la
crianza de los niños
y luego descubrieron este tipo de
lugares eran entornos muy muy
favorecedores para la vida siendo mayor
nosotros en españa nos empezamos a
llamar jubilares les gustaba la palabra
porque viene del latín jubilaré que es
gritar de alegría
y ya son cientos de personas mayores las
que están viviendo o construyendo este
tipo de comunidades autopromo vidas auto
gestionadas y con diseño participativo
son entornos donde hay una intención
clara de vida comunitaria
no son comunes porque siempre hay un
espacio para la vida privada pero es un
lugar donde hay muy buen equilibrio
entre entre apoyo y reto porque en lo
físico construyen
espacios accesibles
adaptables las nuevas situaciones que
puedan venir y en lo social son lugares
donde están realizando siempre
actividades significativas para ellas
porque las deciden ellas les contaba
al principio cuando los talleres en
barcelona preguntábamos al grupo y que
quiere ser de mayor y había uno que dijo
profesor de ruso
le pregunté y esto pues mira que si es
que aprendí ruso y me gustaría enseñarlo
muy bien así que pregunte al resto del
grupo si alguien quiere aprender ruso y
levantar la mano cinco o seis
qué bueno
ahí tienes tu proyecto que va a poderse
hacer realidad por estas personas y por
cierto hay un proyecto para cinco o seis
personas nuevo inimaginados
bueno estas situaciones permiten
precisamente aumentar o mejorar las
capacidades funcionales durante el
envejecimiento para todo esto que os
cuento seguramente que os suena mucho
porque aquí en guadalajara
venimos mayoritariamente de los pueblos
y estas cosas pasaban en los pueblos
antes no pero en los pueblos no podemos
elegir a nuestros vecinos y eso es muy
buena verdad pero pero de estos modelos
de coja o sin podemos aprender muchas
cosas herramientas de facilitación de
grupos metodologías participativas
podemos aprender a escuchar las
necesidades de los demás a poder
expresar las nuestras a trabajar en
equipo ejercer liderazgos compartidos
todo esto es aplicable a nuestras
comunidades a nuestras comunidades de
vecinos se imagina es una reunión de
propietarios con esta caja de
herramientas que viene que va a ir
pues sabéis quién está desarrollando
todo esto ahora mismo
las personas mayores
en españa las personas mayores esa
generación que decimos que son un gasto
que están invisibilizadas
estás por cierto es una generación la
que ha mantenido nos ha mantenido las
familias durante la época de la crisis
es la misma generación nos cuenta muchas
veces dice oye que somos los que
construimos la democracia aquí en españa
y ahora sabéis que nos toca una nueva
revolución
esta misma generación es la que está
ahora mismo trabajando en este otro
proyecto en donde estoy involucrado en
ciudades amigables con las personas
mayores es un proyecto de la
organización mundial de la salud un
programa que plantea una red donde en
españa ya son 165 ciudades
guadalajara es una de ellas
plantea un nuevo una nueva forma de
hacer políticas públicas a partir de la
participación de las personas mayores en
todo el proceso diagnostican proponen
acciones de mejora luego se ejecutan las
acciones se evalúan y así es un proceso
de mejora continua para para mejorar la
amigabilidad de la ciudad en realidad
para todas las edades
se trata de darle voz a este colectivo
hasta ahora invisibilizado
y a través de lo que llamamos grupos
focales son grupos donde nos reunimos y
allí se debaten se hablan de cómo está
la ciudad de las cosas que nos gustan de
lo que podría ser mejorable se pone
muchísima cabeza
entienden que hay
y recursos limitados
porque claro solo los ciudadanos pueden
saber mejor que nadie cómo quieren su
ciudad pues en los últimos meses hemos
podido hemos tenido la oportunidad de
estar trabajando con estos grupos aquí
en guadalajara y ha habido momentos
inolvidables y uno de ellos les quiero
contar el cuándo mabel que está con
nosotros
nos dijo que había nacido en la cárcel
bueno ella era la hija del director de
la cárcel vivían allí por eso nació en
la cárcel estuvimos hablando de nuestro
barrio el al mío también
y dijo que tenía unas fotografías los
negativos que a cabo de unos días me
llevó y hemos podido revelar los y son
estas imágenes
son imágenes de la cárcel de guadalajara
del año 1930 inéditas
y más allá del valor que tienen estas
imágenes como un documento
histórico de este punto de la ciudad
creo que muestra muy bien
ilustran realmente bien la capacidad que
tienen las personas mayores para
devolvernos la memoria
se habla tanto de la pérdida de memoria
de las personas mayores pero sabéis qué
somos nosotros los que la perdemos pero
si son las personas mayores las que nos
traen estos recuerdos las que nos
devuelven la memoria
tienen tanto que aportar las personas
mayores a todas las generaciones
nos enfrentamos en la actualidad a dos
grandes retos
nos afectan a nivel personal local y
global 1 es un castigo por haberlo hecho
fatal las últimas décadas el cambio
climático
y la otra es un premio por nuestro
progreso el envejecimiento poblacional
un premio
pues sabéis qué son las personas mayores
las que están no solo reclamando sino
participando e impulsando soluciones de
mejora de los entornos para afrontar
estos dos grandes desafíos
desde la corresponsabilidad la
sostenibilidad la autonomía personal y
la dignidad de todas las personas sea
cual sea nuestra edad
así que gracias mayores
[Aplausos]
[Música]